in the lobby of Ramsey solutions clay
and Carolyn are with us hey guys how are
ya hi welcome welcome where do you guys
live just outside Atlanta Southside fun
welcome to Nashville good to have you
and you're here to do your debt-free
scream we are I love it and how much
have you paid off grand total was about
two hundred and eighty seven thousand
dollars Wow
and how long did that take sixty six
months very good and your range of
income through that time ranged from
about sixty thousand low-end to about
150 thousand died and Wow what do you
guys do for a living I'm an educational
sales consultant mm-hmm I'm a therapist
oh very good very good
so 287 over sixty six months outside of
Atlanta this must be your house yes you
paid off your house I'm looking at where
people I love it congratulations you
guys very nice so what's this house
worth well we had a house it was worth
about three hundred and ten thousand and
we paid paid a good bit of the debt down
on that and then we sold that and moved
in to downsize into a more appropriately
sized house this is worth about 200 mm
okay
so that was part of the journey then
then we went down the last step very
cool and that enabled you to be
debt-free
yes sir lately very very cool so tell me
the story what happened of five years
and six months ago they started this
journey we had gone through we had been
debt-free actually in our in our past
together but we never really knew kind
of what the next steps were um and so we
kept kind of going back to American
Express thinking it was okay because we
paid it off all the time yeah never
really expected what it was going to be
mm-hmm
so we needed to get better control and
we had heard about your program through
a pastor at the church that we had been
going to and when Clyde came home and
said I think we should do financial
peace I said I think that's a great idea
and so we went through that and we paid
off we had thirty nine thousand dollars
in consumer debt that we paid off pretty
quickly and then
we paid another seventy thousand about a
year after we had started financial
piece maybe six months after we started
financial piece we paid seventy thousand
and refinanced our house to a 15-year
mortgage okay
and then worked on that for a couple of
years until about a year ago right now
when clay said I think a big part of
what's holding us back and getting
further is the house that we were in it
was just very big for us and in five
years our daughter was going to be off
to school and we felt like we would
never go upstairs again there are a lot
of rooms oh yeah I put a pool table in
the room yeah that's exactly right yeah
fun so then that's make the helps you
make the decision to move down so how
many square feet were the big house how
many square feets this one right went
from about 3,000 square feet 3,000
square feet to about 1,600 oh wow yeah
okay very cool very cool what could neat
very neat and perfect just in time to be
empty nesters huh yeah and this is your
daughter that's with you this is their
and Sarah is how old 13 13 okay so about
five years and she'll be I heading off
to school give or take that's what we
hope all right good deal
oh no it's mandatory they have to leave
it yeah she needs to have plan yeah hey
it's good to have you guys so that's
very cool how old are you - I'm 46 and
45 okay and you have a paid-for house
now that's worth approximately what just
over two hundred thousand okay and part
of this was the step down so I'm trying
to kind of put a summation on your story
in my head because you guys are you were
steady but you you know you made these
moves along the way that were smart
moves and there was no herky-jerky about
it was like first we got out of debt
then we refinanced and put 70 thousand
down and got on a 15 and then we moved
down in house and those three moves over
a period of five years really just kind
of no panic no jumping around no
craziness just very steadily making wise
slow decisions got you here is a way
that's the way I'm hearing it does that
sound right it was yeah and there was
there was something
that did happen it was pretty
significant this was last January we've
been talking about it for six months or
so about maybe selling the house and
maybe downsizing and we're sort of
nervous about all the work that goes
into selling a house and it was it was
actually January's my birthday and we
were we're having coffee that morning
getting ready to go to church as a
Sunday morning and we were saying you
know what I think maybe maybe we need to
do this then we went to church and the
message that day was about creating
financial margin in your life in order
to be a better better steward of God's
gifts as we were sitting in the service
kind of okay I guess that God I heard
you make this happen
I heard you god yeah it's like it's in a
sermon just for you that's amazing
that's good
very NIM so what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is now that
they they know they're talking of
somebody didn't have a house payment
that's so weird
yeah I think the big thing for us was
just being able to go through a
financial piece together and getting
focused and really getting on the same
page and having the same goals
I you know it sounds like that's what
everybody says but that was huge to us
may will be our 20th anniversary and I
think the past six years we've been
closer than we'd ever been yeah I think
the budget I know you talk about all the
time but I just don't see how you can
really do this without having that that
marks on paper in front of you let me
plan it out that's that's to me is is
just where it where it all starts and
ends you're right it changes the whole
equation it does so now really when you
all start this Sarah was a little girl
was so she's kind of grown up in this
weird financial peace house um has it
affected her and in any negative way she
in counseling or we know a good one
Justin no you think she you think she's
getting this stuff I think so I think
she is Carolyn tells a story about
taking her shopping and to buy some
pajamas which Sarah had to it was
responsible for paying for out of the
money that she earned from us and she
was looking at one set of one pair of
pajamas it was Hello Kitty and another
pair that was identical but was about
half the price and her sort of
scratching her head and going why would
I pay twice for the one with the picture
of Hello Kitty on it and just to be
clear that wasn't last week no no
years ago I was a little and then yeah
I'm thinking okay so we were pretty
proud that was just sort of an example
of her sort of getting it read between
the lines and seeing what work we're
trying really hard to teach her good
good yeah that's so it's kind of fun to
watch your kids have light bulb moments
like that where they very cool well
congratulations you too I'm very very
proud of you you're heroes man and you
took control of your life you got 20 25
30 years here you're going to become so
wealthy and being able to be so generous
and have so much margin that's pretty
neat very cool very cool so we're going
to give you a copy of Chris Hogan's
retire inspired book that's the next
chapter is continue to build wealth and
be outrageously generous also he'll help
you do that with this number one
best-selling book
hold on or hold on at the end and we'll
make sure we get that for you but right
now it's clay and Carolyn and Sarah
$287,000 paid off in 66 months making 60
to 150 they paid off their house and
everything baby
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream 3 2 1 we're debt-free
I love it love it love
very well done you two you three very
well done very well done that's how it
works so 46 years old their houses paid
off and they did it in five years and
six months they did move down on house
but they made that decision the average
person that starts this program with
Financial Peace University the book the
Total Money Makeover listening to this
show
it gets intense and gets focused and
decides they're going to live their life
on purpose instead of accidentally like
most people do is paying off their home
in seven years that's the average
averages mean that some do it faster and
some - it's slower but that's the
average so maybe you're twice as long as
the average so maybe it takes you
fourteen years what else you got to do
what else you're going to be doing I
read these articles a guy sent me an
article this morning some guy wrote
don't pay off your house it's stupid to
pay off your house minutes tell you you
pay off your house and somebody tells
you you're stupid you're just going to
roll your eyes at them and go you're an
idiot
is when you have paid for house you know
what you've got financial peace two
words that don't go together like
airline service this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show